let me just rescue this
[Music]
this is the intensive care unit at
warrington hospital
almost exactly a year ago it admitted
its first covert 19 patients
in that time it has witnessed daily
battles
of life and death we ran this
ward in october last year and it looks
almost exactly the same it's still full
of very sick
covered patients in this bed here
was mark
so to be honest with me it's still early
days
i felt very fortunate to be here
mark was admitted as the second wave
started to sweep
across the northwest the last time i saw
you
you were pretty poorly yes how are you
now a lot better
i think uh one of the challenges of
corvid is
it sort of goes on for quite a while and
the reality is you have good days and
bad days it was quite a
frightening time really because you
don't know how it's going to evolve
where it's going to go
and i was well looked at i looked after
here at
warrington they clearly knew what they
were doing so there was there was
confidence and comfort that you got from
how you were how you were treated and
they're obviously at risk themselves
the second wave was proving to be busier
and deadlier than the first
in the bed next to mark was susan
like mark the 72 year old grandmother
needed help
with her breathing i know how far i can
breathe at the minute
and i know i can't survive without this
i don't think she ever thought for one
minute you know that she was going in
there to die
initially i thought you know what
they'll take her in they'll give her a
bit of a help with some oxygen
you know she she's happy she's upbeat
all the time she's going to get through
this
when we met susan told me she was
hopeful of getting better and going home
but her daughter claire told me that day
never came she went into hospital
on the 7th of october and on the 22nd of
october she died so that's you know
two weeks she liked to joke she liked to
have a laugh
she was kind of very happy-go-lucky you
know she had a lot of friends she put a
lot into life
two patients of the same warden would
cover 19
two patients with two very different
outcomes
one year on and we're still learning
about this deadly virus
but one thing is certain it's
unpredictability
i've been doing this game a long long
time and
you inevitably identify key risk factors
but as you've highlighted you can get
two patients that are virtually the same
on admission one does well and survives
one does very badly and
sadly doesn't make it and that's been
covered all along
susan died on the same day mark was
discharged
it shows you you know it's how can you
describe first of all there's an element
of feeling lucky that
i've come through it i think the one
thing that's that's clear on this virus
that i've seen for myself is
how how variable it can be as mark
begins to rebuild his life so too
must susan's heartbroken family it's
been
difficult i mean i i'm coming to terms
with it there's there's days i s
even now i still go oh i'll just tell
mom that and then oh
can't do that anymore she wouldn't want
us to sit here crying about it she would
be kind of come on you know pick
yourselves up
i'm still here i'm just not here
one life changed another life
taken the indiscriminate nature of a
virus
that has devastated so many lives
ashish joshi sky news warrington